who do you think has the best shot
in the league there he goes with a
one timer and he scored the great eight
strikes again alexin other than Obie you
just took away my go-to answer can't be OB
the best shot in the league not of etkin
his bad shot is probably the second
best but then third best uh pasta KN
pasta I think pasta has the best shot I think
his release is incredible very deceiving he
hides where he wants to put it the way it just
pops off the stick is pretty impressive it's
very deadly on the power play Cut finishes wow
Nathan McKinnon you can't really read where the
[__] is going off this Slade I think m is
right up there Steven stos has the best shot
in the league he can score with the Slap
Shot the onetime the wrist shot go shoots
score I got to go with Patrick l he's my
good friend and this answer will make him
happy Tage Thompson has the best shot in the
league right now Thompson wow his release and
his one ERS are yeah really heavy he's kind of
adopted ob's office over there he's got a good
good onetime for Thompson there's he has the
best shot for sure I think a lot of guys would
say Matthews right Matthews Austin Matthews
Matthews Matthew Matthew Matthews what a shot
from Austin Matthews his quick release just
gets it off really quick his release is so
quick I wish I could tell you what
made it special why can't I do I
know four Austin Matthews that's a beauty the
way he pulls the puck in Pull It in tight to
his body his ability to to pull the [Music] puck
his ability to change the angle change the angle
oh he changes the angle can shoot the puck from
all different angles shoot it from any what a shot
so good at getting it off and really accurate
just a sniper pretty pretty Elite I'd probably
say he's the best shooter just Snipes gets a
lot of goals that guy here's Matthew scores
Matthew Matthew entire scores Matthew score if
you're a leaf fan how many times have you seen
that